welcome back we just found out for
another breaking news sexual harassment
claim now against Congressman John
Conyers he's apparently accused of using
government resources to fly women and
with whom he was having affairs as these
stories are actually coming out during
the show they're coming out so fast and
furious so I had to update you on that
and another absolutely crazy story
coming out of a university or college
and this one out of Dartmouth College
and I graduated from Dartmouth just a
few years ago on February 2nd the
college is scheduled to hold a forum
called what's up with white people the
event will feature Temple University
sociologist Matt ray and he plans to
provide a quote field guide for quote
the different types of white people and
how you can learn to spot them in their
natural habitats
sounds like the mutual of Omaha's Wild
Kingdom Dartmouth released a statement
saying it's committed to robust debate
and told Fox News that the professor
raid does not represent the views of the
college joining us now for reaction from
LA is tarik Nasheed a film producer who
also builds himself as an anti racism
strategist all right take it away Tariq
how is this and we don't know what
exactly is gonna happen and that's but
you've got kind of a summary how is this
not going to foment more racial division
since it's based on quote whiteness I
think that the professor should have
worded it differently now I do disagree
with what's up with white people as the
title because white people are not the
problem and I don't like to paint
everybody with one broad brush you have
white people and you have like
supremacist and I think that it should
have been entitled what's up with white
supremacy or how can we dismantle and
understand white supremacy so the whole
thing of painting all white people with
a broad brush I definitely disagree with
that but it's a very interesting topic
if we want to talk about the ins and
outs and how systemic white supremacy
dominates all areas of activity so white
so it's your contention that white
supremacy dominates all areas of
activity
yes ma'am all every year every area of
activity between human beings labor law
entertainment sex war politics religion
and that's the dominance the domineering
system yes and the NBA is dominated by
white supremacist how to explain that
yes because the you have white team
owners who say that their teammates or
that their team players are inmates and
slaves Donald sterling even referred to
his players as slaves and look at what
how they're being treated now they're
protesting non justice and they're
getting blacklisted from team so that
just shows and proves that sports has
even dominated ultimately by systemic
white supremacy so what would your
solution be to that would you think that
there should be a mandatory distribution
of ownership assets based on percentage
ethnicity or race in the country and
kind of do it in a kind of fanned out
panoply of proportionality well the
figures how white supremacy works it's
all about Mao distributing the resources
and it's all about passing those mail
distributed resources down through
lineages so we have to talk about
redistributing those those resources
that are deserving to the people who are
supposed to get it systemic white
supremacy it works based on deception
and works through propaganda and that's
something that we have to talk about and
we have to flesh out I want to replace
the system of white supremacy with
justice because not only do we get it
when it comes to resources in the
criminal justice system it's a racially
biased system so it all across the board
it's a conversation that we should have
naturally on how we remove and replace
the system of white supremacy so my
answer is the solution so you believe it
should it be a monetary payout should it
be monetary plus land or plus business
ownership I'm just trying to get the
solution air straight I've been on
solutions for a long time and we've been
trying to figure out how do we some
realities systemic white supremacy we
know when we try to get people when we
try have an idea it's called hard work
ma'am a content of your character you
say are you saying that black people
don't do hard work now
saying that black people don't be nice
nice try nice trachmann i'm saying
everybody does that you said black
people don't do hard work the reason why
you have all the resources mal
distributed people my friend that's not
straight ahead you know it isn't that's
the game you play